so rock that's the lineup that will face
eric lauer we'll see how long he'll be
able to go i think for lauer wants to
get right back in his rotation spot now
he's fourth in overall hits in the nl
and he chases another one
made him look bad lauer nice start one
two three in it with a strikeout
and for the pirates making his pirate
debut bryce wilson best pitch to date
has been the change up
there it is
it's an easy pop-up nagowski says scram
radofo and one out under wilson's belt
powers got himself in a bit of a pickle
here two on but there are two outs to
strike pitch and shoots it right to
teles
he'll take it a line drive out tyrone
taylor is up there now with escobar
still at first two outs
this is line toward the left center
field gap reynolds is over diving catch
he's done it again
brian reynolds leaping into the air like
superman
spectacular again
every night this guy
and
they keep getting better and better that
might be his best catch of the year i
mean
diving into the gap toward the wall at
an angle
and just stealing extra bases
incredible incredible absolutely
jaw-dropping
we may run out of batteries but we'll
try
fly ball to right hit well
back is garcia and he leaps he's got it
it wouldn't have gone out but it gave
lauer a scare
[Applause]
just in front of the wall the six foot
four it's garcia ranges to pull it down
3-2 pitch
swinging a chopper this is going gonna
be trouble charging fielding bottling
kane's got a hit
was gonna be a tough enough play for
hayes
without the bobble
but for lorenzo kane
another bullet for a base
set first hit of the game for the
brewers
infield hit low kane making contact
busting it down that line
best chance you have to sacrifice buns
with a national league lineup pitcher
batting with a runner
[Applause]
play no play
[Applause]
evans thrown to the plate he's got a
great arm but that's off the mark king
scores
sack flying an rbi for colton wong and
the producer strike first he'll take
that and a one or two count
once that ball got in the air he knew he
was deep enough to score lorenzo
great speed waited long enough easy run
for the brewery in field hit stolen base
scores on the sac fly edwardo escobar is
going to be the battery
escobar rolls over one that's down the
right field line fair
hits the wall and a bounce fell by is on
his horse he's gonna be waved home and
no throw
escobar in the third
it's an rbi for escobar
two-nothing brewers
[Applause]
breaking pitch out away from nice and
easy swing just trying to put the ball
in play
maybe to rip it down in the corner
and avaya is running on contact with two
outs able to score without a throw
big hit
two out run producing hit for escobar
one and two the count
and that hit him
looks like he got him in the elbow
yeah that opens the door for the
intentional walk and they'll load the
bases here
3-2 runners go and ball four
just missed taylor draws a walk where
the bases loaded and he did go with the
slider he just barely missed that
outside corner
good take by tyrone i think he just
fooled that it wasn't a fastball
a little bit off the outside corner
really tough pitch to take
all the ball and another run in
that story always gets you that favorite
image
bouncing ball escobar fires to second
out there long's throw in time
close play rodolfo castro
hustling down the line pirates are gonna
look at this here
it was bang bang
ball on the field out at first for an
inning ending double play and what's
wrong how quickly he gets rid of that
baseball and on its way with something
on it
and no talent
long does and it's in the dirt wall will
turn he's on his way to third stalling's
throw comes in wong is in there
pushing the envelope
cold wall goes from first to third
pretty close to third base but he saw
the ball go to the screen
never slowed down around second base
just a slight hesitation by stars to get
the ball to third base is why he's safe
sliding to the outfield side of the bag
that's what got him runners on the
corners now for eduardo escobar
here it comes escobar
way back
wagon
free run blast
that guy's gonna fit in
very nicely
in a brewer uniform
second homer is the brewer his first
here at american family field
[Applause]
and a knockout punch perhaps in the
seventh inning 3-1 fastball
don't miss it he did not haymaker
tonight for the brewers
no doubt up in the bleachers second
level got to enjoy all of that
the axe man
last time he pitched in a major league
game
september 21st of 2018.
this is his first appearance as a brewer
for the first time since 2013
and in a shocking development at 38
years of age here is john oxford
and oxford misses
and
his expert calling i think he's calling
out the trainer i think he's hurt
and oxford is
on his way out
well
[Applause]
didn't have the storybook finish but
he'll exit with a
standing ovation
they are loaded up ninth inning and the
screws tighten a little bit more it is
six to two now
fox burger deals and a cold strike three
ball game over
box burger saves it pirate strand the
base is loaded and the brewers win
tonight in game one of the home stand
eduardo escobar rock had the big hit a
three run home run on the seventh
it is american family field debut he is
not disappointed